what are the basic principles of
virology
maybe a good place to start is what is a
virus that's great i mean i talk in my
first lecture for 20 minutes before i
get to that
but and i wonder if i should put it up
front but it's kind of a boring
definition so if you do that first
people will turn off so first you tell
them about all the millions and billions
of viruses around so a virus
we have a very specific definition
because it's different from everything
else on the planet
um because first of all it's a parasite
it takes a parasite means you take
something
from someone else and we have human
parasites who take money from others
right but in biological terms
a parasite takes something from the host
that the host would otherwise use energy
or some building block or something
there's never really a symbiotic
relationship between a virus and a host
well there can be so that's the
dichotomy i think is that we define them
as parasites yet i just told you 20
minutes ago that many viruses are
probably beneficial
so i think
what it means is we at some point we're
going to have to change our definition
right because
after all definitions we make are just
constructs that make it easier for us to
study that not necessarily represent
what's right yeah right like uh like
pluto was a planet at first and now it's
not a planet anymore and a lot of people
are very upset but it's only according
to us there may be another race living
somewhere else who thinks it's a planet
right well maybe that's why viruses are
attacking humans they're very angry they
weren't
calling them parasites so
right now our definition includes
parasite
because a virus cannot do anything
without a cell
if if this mug were full of viruses it
would not do anything for years it would
eventually probably lose its infectivity
but it's not going to reproduce here it
needs cells
and you know to the first people who
discovered viruses that was astounding
that
they didn't just reproduce divide on
their own like bacteria so a virus needs
to get inside of a cell
inside the cell it can't just hang
around on the surface it needs to get in
in order to make more of itself and so
we call it an obligate intracellular
parasite because it needs to get in a
cell and then it takes things
from the cell in the form of all kinds
of molecules and processes and energy
and so forth to make new viruses
uh obligate means it's obligated to be
inside the cell absolutely it will not
reproduce
outside of the cell so this
mug of viruses is can in no way be
living in my opinion however once it
gets inside of a cell now the cell is a
virus infected cell it's alive so a
virus in my view has two phases right
it's this non-living particulate phase
that everyone is used to
uh yeah i'll send you you need a virus
for your table i'll send you a nice
model i think it would look good here
yes you have to go with all this other
stuff yeah well these are all mechanical
there's no biology here so you wouldn't
want a virus here no i'd want to buy of
course i'll send you one and look at
that you can look at it because now that
we have
the three-dimensional structures solved
by structural biologists we take the
coordinates so we put it in a 3d printer
and you can make amazing models right
of any virus and so there's a huge
variety of viruses huge that we know of
yeah which is only a fraction of what's
out there what's the categories so
there's rna there's dna viruses what
what are those what's dna and rna two
two
broad categorizations rna and these are
genetic material can be two different
chemicals
so rna
everything else on the planet besides
viruses is all dna based you and i are
dna based everything on the planet today
is dna based except some viruses are
rna-based and that's because as i
mentioned earlier the first
life that arose on the planet was
rna-based yeah so these are like
old-school viruses these are old school
these are we call relics yeah
they're relics and this has got a name
it's called the rna world which i think
is great is it big still or are they are
the relics dying out oh no the relics in
my opinion are the most successful
viruses the rna viruses and the source
cov2 is an rna virus we can talk about
why they're so successful but you have
broadly speaking viruses with rna
genetic information which are relics of
course they're contemporary they have
adapted to the modern world
and the modern organisms living in it
and then we have dna based viruses which
are extremely conservative
and slow they're very successful you
know everyone has a herpes virus
infection but
they
they don't get the news like the rna
viruses do the hivs and the influenza
viruses and the sars coronaviruses they
get all the press and they're rna-based
because rna lets you change
more so than dna so they they've evolved
much faster rna viruses much faster and
in fact when i i have lecture on
evolution i don't know if you've
listened to that one you should it's
really i think it's really interesting
rna viruses exist
at
their error threshold
which means they can't make any more
mutations when they reproduce otherwise
they're dead
they
think they're they're evolving at their
error threshold
dna viruses are hundreds of times lower
than their error thresholds
and we know this we can do an experiment
to find that out now why that is is a
good question
but uh
that's the that's the reason why rna
viruses are far more successful they in
fact many more hosts
and they're very i would say slippery
they can change hosts really quickly
because in any animal harboring an rna
virus
like let's say a bat in some cave
somewhere it's not just one genome it's
it's millions of different genomes of
all
kinds with all within the framework of
say coronavirus but they're all
different and one genome in there might
just be right for infecting a person if
it ever encountered that person i mean
that's the thing that oh there could be
a large number this is a tiny fraction
but a large number of uh of them and
they're all operating at the threshold
of
error that's right that's fascinating
it's like a little like uh it's like
startups little entrepreneurs like a
startup world yes and many of them fail
yeah many of the changes and then
there's the dna of ours that are like
the ibm and exactly exactly big
corporations it's very good they become
conservative with the bureaucracies and
all that kind of stuff so there's a lot
of baggage yeah yeah it's expensive for
them to reproduce yeah and they don't
move quickly yes the rna viruses are the
fast moving
members so that's what a virus is we
call them
obligated intracellular parasites and
then i told you there's dna in rna but
then let's go further
the the nucleic acid is not naked
because naked nucleic acid in the world
isn't good i mean it it existed in the
in the pre-cellular world but there
probably weren't a lot of threats to it
then
naked nucleic acid doesn't last long in
the environment so they're they're
covered the nucleic acid is covered it
can be covered with a protein shell a
pure protein shell
or it can have a membrane
around it which would be
lipids from the host cell
so
lipids so it's a fatty membrane fatty
membrane yeah so our cells are
coated with fatty membranes right our
cells the outer plasma membrane right
that's the same viruses can be too so
they're kind of like cells but without
the ability to do the mitochondria stuff
some some are some they don't have
nuclei they don't have mitochondria yeah
but they do have a nucleic acid they
have a membrane and then of course there
are spikes in the membrane
that allow them to attach to cells
and so that completes our two different
kinds so they have they all have like
attachment mechanisms like ways to
like keys into the into the cell they
all have to get into cells
there are
there are a couple of exceptions though
uh there are viruses of fungi
uh and uh plants
so let's do the fungi fungi would be
like yeast
uh the virus yeast cell wall is pretty
hard to get through so
viruses typically don't attach to a
yeast and get inside rather they just
live in the yeast forever yeah and they
multiply as mostly nucleic acids and as
the yeast divide they go into the
daughter cells and that's how they exist
plant viruses also the plant cell wall
would be very hard to get across with a
by binding a protein
so plant viruses get into plants either
by
pests that inject them in
they're sucking sap out and they inject
virus at the same time or farmers they
have contaminated farm equipment and
they roll over the plants and introduces
viruses so those fungi and plant viruses
they don't have this specific receptor
binding to get them into the cell but
everything else yeah the virus binds to
something on the surface very specific
it's taken into the cell because that's
what cells do
when things bind their exterior
they take it in because in most cases
it's good it's something they need
and so the virus slips in i guess you'd
call that a trojan horse right frozen
horse it's so hard to not
anthropomorphize this whole thing it is
hard so obviously they don't know any of
this
it's not an actual trojan horse
so that they
they're not getting actually tricked in
the way humans trick each other no it's
all passive and it's just through so
many years of evolution it's you select
something that works
and it continues and what survives then
goes on with the
perhaps a slightly different approach
i love this idea of past of course
according to sam harris uh so from a
sufficiently intelligent alien
civilization observing humans our
behavior might seem passive too because
they understand fully exactly what we're
doing and then there's no free will and
we're all just operating in the same way
it could be a cell does which is a much
higher level of complexity
yeah so i love the distinction between
active and passive i mean the point is i
think anthropomorphizing to a certain
extent is fine because it helps people
understand
but when you start to say i think the
virus is doing that because then you're
putting a human lens on it and you may
be wrong
yeah because you don't know why things
happen
for a virus
um so right now we have variants
emerging and people say well i think
it's because the antibodies are
selecting for variants
that's a good idea but it may not be the
only thing that's going on you start
imagining them coming to the table
negotiating
yeah
you get into trouble with that that's
right that's why i tell my students be
careful about the anthropomorphizing
because
you're going to apply your values to a
virus and you have different values
you're human and you have
what you think is the reason for this
outcome may not be right that's all just
be open-minded
about it in both directions i actually
one of the things that push back
on is in in the space of robotics people
most people in robotics try to not
anthropomorphize for example they don't
give a gender or a name to robots they
really try to see as a machine and to me
that makes sense in one in one way but
it totally doesn't make sense in another
if that robot is to interact
operate in the human world and interact
with humans
we have to we have to anthropomorphize
it in order to understand
as an engineering problem
how should it operate in a human world
now the difference with viruses the
scale of operation
it doesn't make sense to treat them as
human-like because the scale of
operations is much smaller but with
robots you're in the same sure time
scale the same spatial skills of course
in the movies they always give them
names and personalities yeah well yeah
that's the move but that's my argument
is we should do the same when you're
trying to solve the engineering problem
of robotics too it's not just for the
movies
you